お兄ちゃーん
ライゾマティクス最強ですあのたドライずもと聞くと大体ライブエンターテイメントと
かテクノロジーを使って5とかそういうことまあ
想起させると思いますが広告とかですね
なんですが今日話す内容は冷凍今僕たちがやっていることは僕個人もやってることが
ものすごい広がってます
なので今のイントロダクションにもえっだったように東京どう考えるかとかもしくは
都市開発をどう考えるかみたいなところまで
今ないぞまあいろんな業務をさせていただいてます
ええええええ
で統計の写真ありますがえーと今あの先ほど長谷部口調からもありましたとおり
東京はどんどん変わってます特に2020年に向けて
渋谷もそうですしえっと他の東京のいろんな間違え変わり始めているとそれっていうの
は古いものを壊し
新しいものを立てるって言うのもそうですし古いものを残しそれをリノベーションして
新しいものを作るという破産もあります
で僕自身はどう
葉山に神奈川葉山に住んでるんですけど僕がの会社をやっているがそこの恵比寿でやっ
て言って毎日1時間2時間かけてた葉山リカ阿山から東京に来るんですけど
いつも高速乗って東京みると何かおかしいなと思うんですよね
何かおかしいなっていうのは僕自身これはもう
センスとして感じるものなんですけど東京がこのままだと面白くなくなるんじゃないか
と思っていると
それを面白くなくなるんじゃないかというのはなんでかっていうと
新しく町がバンバンまたってで商業主義的に同じようなコンテンツがいろんな街で着て
いくとそうなると最終的には東京が何か大きなデパートになるというか
要は今までて秋葉原あったら電気街とか
まあ横歩こうもいろんな潜ったのに的
よくその文化が聞いてしまってそれが塗り替えられてしまうのではないかっていうのを
個人的にすごく感じてば
でえっこういう頭がですね一昔前
超複雑系みたいな話でえっとよく語られてたんですけど
えっと僕が思っているのは今の産業構造
それというのは業界的な構造がだいぶ変わってきたと思ってまして
これはまあ特にインターネットがもしくはテクノロジーが発展したからこそ
えーと今まで全く関係ないと思っていた業界が実はものすごく関係がある here
ウザスケっていうのはえっともちろん60年代にもう80年代にも2000年代にも
語られていたんですけどその構造がしっかりと植えてきたのはここ数年でこれから
もっともっと
全く違う業界が関係があるというのが見えてくることになると思う
ます
[音楽]
ブーバパティがう例えば here
は未来のテクノロジーとか実は全然違う業界で起こっていたことが
えっとものすごく関係性を持っているとへというところが
これから
近所に見れると思うんです
でそのときに今日の8てとのイントロでもあったような一番最初踊りだす人でこの人
たちはいったい誰なのかと
8僕はすごくを持って行って
で僕が思っているのが1人の9ディ自分として僕自身が
ものを作っている人間で8何か
まあ考えて
ゼロからものを作る人間ですよねでや僕はクリエイティブじゃないよっていう人は
たぶんこの中には絶対なくて誰しもがものを作ることができる
もしくは何かを考えて想像することができる絶対そうだと思うんですよ
で僕は一人をクリエイティブとしてえーっこのアクションは一番最初に踊り出すような
人になろうと思って今行動しています
here 最近だと自動折りたたみ
ちっません
氷たた道とか7通りばあさんの八尾関わらせていただいたり
神樹さんのメガネの中にセンサーを入れたものとかっていうのも大内も協議をさせて
いただいています
8その他に強制と一緒にあるようなプロジェクト例えば
万博であるとかそういうものも一緒にやってますしえっとその他に今坂万博の招致も
やってうますしあとは震災復興みたいなことをやらせていただいています
なので一番最初は報告
コンテンツ制作からなぜいま都市開発みたいなまで広がったのかと
その発想をちょっとご紹介します
で僕自身がまあ一プリエーティとしていつも活動したですか
活動する中で実はいろんな人と話す機会があるんですね
here
方々といろいろ話す機会があってたぶん皆さんもそうだと思うんですけど日々の中で
いろんな話を聞くこと
もしくはえっともちろん超機密事項なことを仕事8して聴く場合があるところですで
もちろんその nd を8結んで
いる情報に関して他の人に言うことできないじゃないですか
ただあと真ん中で自分の頭の中に全部あるわけですね
この街はこうなるんだとかこのメーカーさんはこういうものを作るんだとか
例えば新しいモビリティを2020年に出そうとしてるんだとかそういうことが頭の中
にあるんであれば
1そのいろんな情報もって人間としてそれを何らかしらの子覚えたも伝えていかなきゃ
いけないですね
どうしてもいやその情報っていうのはこの仕事のためだけに使うから他に扱えないと
いいですけどそれはそれでその通りなんですが
でも情報が入ってるからこそ何か我々
クリーというものを作る人間がアクションするとじつはいろんなものが変わっていくん
じゃないかとというふうに思っています
てい
でそれをいろんな情報を持ったからこそ中次のアクションをしてみるともうしかした
東京が少しでも良くなるのではないかと
a というふうに思っています
day
here
をちょっとえっとご紹介させていただいています
米英とその考え方の前提に列に僕が持っているものが
えっと捨て駒っていう8
考え方
7号待って何かっていうと僕は別に政治的な背景もないし何大きな企業やってるわけで
もないのでえっ僕のスターコツとしては超時期にあるべきものを8あるべき形で何か
表現するもしくは実行するように8政治的な背景なしで全部
障子に言ってるんですね
here 2年後に僕がてされているかもしれませんがその時は雷蔵の斉藤さんなんか
地雷を踏んでしまったティオってください
ただニョクに対しても行政に対してもメーカー三対一あなたの会社わー
こういうことをやるべきだとかええとあなたの街はこういうことをすべきだみたいな
ことを正直に入るお話しています
here とエヴァ
農業界
ひぁっそうでどんどん
どんどん作っていくと実は面白いものが8どんどん生まれると思っています
まず一つ目へと例としてお話をさせていただける話をさせていただくのが3 d ま
3 d としまったですねで僕の発想としてえーどう
まあ守備はも始め渋谷なので他になのでえっともともと単にがですね一番したい母が
流れていて
deen 特に方はえーっとすごい
あの
地形の影響が多くて地形がすごい
のバリエーションに富んでいるからこそこういう街が8できたりとしができたりしてる
んですけど
なので8本当は地図で今の時代は3次元のはずなのになぜ今まだ二次元の絵二像
買っているのかとそういう気もをもちまして
で僕なんかが始めたのがこれは経済産業省であった
えっ3 d せる3 d city スペースはボっていう8まあ
プロジェクトを立ち上げてなぜ3次元で地図を作れないのかっていうのを探求したん
ですねだろうなんで
8そのまあ3 d の地図を作るっていうところも一つ目的になっているんですけど
それにそれを作るための障害って何だろう
例えば泥をはすことができないとかえ取る
金利を持っている人たちが多すぎてその承認が取れないとか
その本題を全部洗い出して8このプロジェクトを作りました
ちょっと映像を見ていただきます
[音楽]
これどこかわかりますか
これ実は渋谷の地下意外なんですね
で実は渋谷の柄が入ってへスキャンをしようと思った人がたくさんいるんですね
でなんですがえっとそれがなかなか出来なかったと
それはなぜかというと a 等級サーガを持ちのところ東京メトロさんがお持ちの
ところ
jr さんがもちろんところ
地上は国土交通省
なのでものすごい許可が取るのが大変でで今日ばが取るのが大変だと皆さんって結構
事前に諦めですね
で僕がやったのは a
まあその時は東京メトロさんと a 棟
特急さんあと国の方一緒にベッド全部見て回って
であの渋谷歩いていただくとわかると思うんですけど
上に東京メトロとか渋谷とかあのは東急とかあるんですね実は床のタイルもえっと
メトロと東北部違ったりします
で非常に複雑なのをえっと僕たちとしてはじゃあこれ
いろんな人に聞かれるのが何でやったんですかって言われるんですけど何がその8
経済だったのかもしくはコンテンツのためなのかいろいろありますけど男女僕たちが見
たいものを作りたい
a というからこそをこれをつくってみたものでございます
で将来的には8実は3 d スキャンのものっていうのはまあ当たり前のようにあると
例えば手芸後彼がどれだけ複雑になっているのか
じゃあ道案内にも使えるかもしれないですしその中を物理のドローンを飛ばすような
こともできますかも知れ
しできるかもしれないしあとは何にせよこういうようなコンテンツとして将来的に vr
とか ar とかアップもあるとかそういうものにも使えるんじゃないかなと思ってい
ます
でもう一つの泳動事例として
iot を不審靴ってマーキー行くものの iot かと言っている
プロジェクトがあってまあ internet of things 欲しい靴だって
越冬用は
もの
物理的にあるもののヘッドデータベース化することで実は新しいコンテンツができると
いうものですね
で81964東京 vr っていう
一般車の北条立てて a 8これあのにってるの8 t 部長って後
金髪のそれこそ電波少年を作ったあの部長と a
一緒にやってるプロジェクトなんですけどえーとこれは東急さーん
あとは8長谷部口調にもご協力いただいてえええっとぉ
何をやっている方がいいです
ちょっと見ていただければわかると思います
[音楽]
お預けください
スプリング走りメロん
レジェンドはいけない
me
[音楽]
nwn
ああああああ
ni ore
から無塩タイプん
エビげな目もいいんこエンストが5分セリー
言いん
wiki ファインのウィッグてもいいん
me
僕の劇的タイガーえーっに10月から始まったんですがいい
皆さん見ては彼の通り1964年の写真を教えに入っている写真を集めて
a それを集めることで実は3点測量のえっとゲーマーこの
ものを3つの視点からみるとじつはこれは3次元ができるんですね
フォトグラメトリーというもので
で
8いろいろ集めた写真を使って渋谷1964年の渋谷を3次元で再現しようと a と
いうプロジェクトをやっております
実際に映像の最後に出てきたのが今3次元で表現されているものですね
これもなぜ行ったのかっていうと僕たちが見たいからですんで8これもうブルー王者の
プロジェクトで箸走っているので
えええええ
今日排除とか8例えば a 社さんが入った b 社座が入れないみたいなことをしか
新聞社が8いくつも入ってちゃダメみたいなことはなく誰でも入れるように馬車が放銃
を a という作って展開しています
day
僕がものすごいそのいろんなアクション
まあいろんな情報が入って切ってるからこそ自分でアクションすることでまぁ一人目の
を撮る人になろうというふうに持っているのが良くデザインピングっていうその考え方
の話は出てくると思うんですけど僕はもう今考えてる暇はない
思ってるんですね
考えるよりもえっとまずアクションすることで失敗してもいいです
別に失敗なってつきものなんで今 pdca とかと言われてますけど
まずは悪書をしていくことで実はいろんなものが変わり here クソ幼いと8
例えばビルだったら知らぬも勃っちゃってるんでっ
できるだけ皆さんいろんな情報を持っている方
それ皆さんだと思うんですけどできるだけアクションを起こして自分が見たいもの
もしくは世の中でこうあるべきものっていうのをどんどんどんどん作ってえっと入って
もらえたらなぁと思っています
まあもちろん2020年に向けてえーっともうしか25年の8大阪の万博今承知して
ますけどに向けていろんなものが変わり始めてます
で8なんにせよやっぱり人間が街の中で全てのものでも中心なので我々
自分たち一人ひとりが思う頃っていうのを開く
消灯してより良い世界を作ってい k
舞踏いいなと思っております
ありがとうございました
[拍手]